i'd like to pull up this story we have
here from the daily mail
gop leader kevin mccarthy claims biden's
plan to forgive ten thousand dollars in
student loans is to distract from his
failing agenda and stunt to subsidize
degrees of the elite and leave working
americans paying the tab for all of my
progressive friends who are sitting here
saying i don't understand why anyone
would be opposed to forgiving student
loan debt don't you want to make
people's lives better you're just saying
you want them to suffer because you
suffered let me explain something very
simply what i'm saying
is that i do not believe the government
should take from the poor to give to the
higher income earners
low-income earners will be paying the
sub paying the taxes that subsidize
high-income earners getting their debt
cleared and the high-income earners who
have the debt got to spend that money
and do things with it now i am for
student debt forgiveness i say we tax
the universities and seize the
endowments and forgive all the student
loans that way but if you're going to
tell me that you are a reverse robin
hood who wants to steal from the poor to
give to the rich i'm gonna say screw off
yeah also whenever someone says
something like i can't imagine why
anyone would oppose forgiving student
loan debts like why would you admit that
you're telling you're telling on
yourself dude that's really embarrassing
it's actually not that hard to figure
out because it's a regressive tax people
who get degrees actually do tend to make
more money and the idea that someone who
a already paid their college off because
they worked through college or already
paid their debt off or
decided to start working in a trade
should be on the hook for the money that
someone else who's making more money
than them voluntarily took on his debt
is insane well i got i got to ask like
do you believe that the government
should forgive student loan debt i said
i don't think it can like what do you
mean of course it can't no no it can't
there's no way when you say forgive what
you're essentially saying is that the
person that lends them to you is now
said you don't owe it back that's not
how the government did this the
government took tax dollars by force and
then distributed in the form of loans
which you voluntarily took so the
government can't forgive that all they
can do is transfer the responsibility
for paying it on to somebody that didn't
take out the loan
right so that's all that's happened this
should never be talked about can the
government forgive student loan debts
should the government transfer student
loan debt off of people that took the
loan and on to people who didn't take
the loan because that's what they're
going to do so i could forgive the
interest i guess hold on what if they
seize the endowments from the
universities or tax the universities to
pay back those loans i mean i i
the bottom line is that legally the the
universities were in a position to be
able to you know again the money went to
the person the student and the student
chose which university that they went to
so as much as i think the university has
totally been in bed with the government
in order to make all this happen
right
i still don't think you could i still
don't think you have legal grounds to go
and seize their property as a result of
this it as much as i would look at it
from kind of a cosmic moral sense and be
like well that you know karma's a you
know well i think the universities are
corrupt
i think the the loan situation is
predatory and i think you get a you get
look we want millennials buying houses
in heaven families many of them are
settled with debt because they were told
to get these loans out and they weren't
smart enough to figure out why they
shouldn't have got that and so i'm like
okay if you want student loan
forgiveness then you got to take it from
those universities that got that money
these are the universities that went to
these students and said you have to do
this what are you going to do unless
they have these they have these um
recruiters at universities who go and
tell you why you need to go there how
much it'll cost then these people go and
get these government-backed loans now
they're in debt okay the system can eat
itself there you go problem solved
oh look from a karma perspective yes
from a legal perspective i don't see how
you do it the people that are the people
that are truly the most responsible for
this or the politicians that advocated
for it because they're the ones they're
the ones that actually cast the little
vote they push the little button saying
yes we should make this a portion of the
budget there's a way to do it without uh
um taking any money from anybody and
that's just terminating interest on all
loans
so you got to pay back the principal if
you borrowed 40 000 from somebody and
you spent 40 000 you got to pay it back
but the interest rates which are
compounding we just delete those
gone because those interests weren't
weren't granted to you that's just them
saying oh it's been 10 years so now we
say you owe us another 50 000. and it's
like well that 50 000 didn't come from
anywhere you're saying i owe it to you
we can get rid of that i mean the
government shouldn't be in the business
of doing these sorts of loans anyways
and that's an incredibly unpopular thing
to say and it is absolutely 100 true
because we've created especially since
most of the universities are are either
public-private partnerships or they're
state-run universities so again this is
this is the government subsidizing
another government agency in order to
push a particular agenda and then it
works out perfect for politicians
because they can then they can first
approve the loans with no intention of
you ever having to fully pay them back
and then come back and say i'm the nice
guy that's going to forgive this when
they know damn well they can't forgive
it they can only transfer it on other
taxpayers yeah well in the real scandal
is that so many people feel they need a
college education in order to make a
living and also that in a number of
circumstances that can actually be the
case we need to ask ourselves if a
person cannot have a well-paying job
with a four-year degree which actually
isn't true but let's just say it were
the case
then why is that and why aren't we
trying to solve the problem of the first
12 years of education that everyone has
provided for free not preparing them for
the marketplace now of course it's
because public school is a racket it's a
horrible system they don't really have
your child's best interest in mind but
a parent who is homeschooling their
child obviously has the best interest of
their child in mind and they're going to
ensure that their child is educated in a
way that will prepare them for the
workforce so they can be a productive
adult
i think it's sad that people think they
need college yeah there's trades
there's entrepreneurial uh
entrepreneurship
well i mean it's you listen to elon musk
talk about this you listen to like gary
vee talking about it it's always the
same thing it's like our schools are not
designed to actually do anything to help
out with entrepreneurial ship it's
designed to make
the best version is designed to make
very good factory workers the worst
version it's designed to make really
good conscripts
and and the problem that i have with all
of it is what did you expect right you
you have the government running an
institution where they don't actually
have to be responsive to the end users
of the customers of the product or the
service that they're providing
because every time we try to pass any
sort of legislation that would even do
something like hey dollars follow
students oh my gosh you hate public
school and you hate public teachers or
public school teachers like no or i just
recognize that like everywhere else in
the marketplace when people have genuine
choices and they can go and find the
services that work best for them you
actually get better quality at lower
prices and more accessibility yeah what
do you think about a voucher system for
schools so
i think there's a couple different ways
you can do it i think the idea of
dollars following students whether you
want to call it a voucher whether you
wanted to make it an education savings
account i think it would be a vast
improvement on what we currently have
what's funny is that the left
immediately comes back and goes you
can't spend public tax dollars for a
private service provider oh you mean
like with wic or ebt or road
construction or jet fighter construction
or i don't know lodging and per diem the
politicians use a private yes section 8
housing like we do it all the time it's
like you know you don't want it here
because you want politicians to actually
control the education of my child and i
don't understand why because half the
time i'm hearing we need to get politics
out of the classroom i know a way to do
it actually give poor parents an
opportunity to be able to do what rich
liberals do with their kids and send
them to private school i i can't tell
you how funny it is when i will talk to
some liberal
and say
they say republicans are banning math
and history and i say well they're
banning praxis they're banning they're
banning critical race praxis the
practice of these theories and they say
yeah but that's important context in
history and i was like dude if you want
ideologies in schools we can start with
the bible because if you think your
ideology should be there why couldn't a
teacher teach any ideology they wanted
how about if you don't want religion in
public schools we then say you can't
have other ideological practices in
those schools all the same or or we just
do this
right i don't want to tell the person
that has an ebt card you're only allowed
to shop at the government grocery store
i've assigned you based off of your
address there wouldn't be any food there
so how about how about how about we do
this you want your kid to learn that you
really think that's the best learning
outcome for your kid okay i might i
might disagree
but i am not going to use the power of
the state to compel you to educate your
child the way i think is best i'm going
to let you make that decision
and if public dollars are following you
can come up with some okay hey they got
to take one test a year or there's got
to be some criteria like you can't take
them to a school that's teaching them
you know violence against other people
whatever that's fine
but you educate your child the way you
think is best i will do the same this
goes right back to the whole socialism
point i made earlier it's not good
enough for them that they be free to do
what they want they must compel me to do
what they want i make no such
requirement of them so which one of us
which ideology is the peaceful tolerant
one that actually appreciates diversity
that's the problem is the right has been
tolerant and peaceful and the left then
took over the institutions while they
were being tolerant and peaceful well i
mean the right is is obsessed with human
respect in being perceived as one of the
good ones by their enemies which is
completely suicidal and stupid i'll also
add that whenever you have these left
wingers who fire back at you for
supporting vouchers by saying you hate
public schools they are admitting that
parents would send their children
anywhere else but public school if they
had the option corey deangelis makes
that point beautifully daily on twitter
like oh
he's fantastic why would the money go
away from public schools if there's an
option they're so good aren't those
public schools incredible aren't they
good for kids but at bottom
what they're saying is okay yes parents
would choose to send their kids
elsewhere but we can't allow them to
have that choice because i
decide how other people's children get
educated not them it's there's some
value to that to to having um uniformity
in education in that like math for
instance if one school teaches the kids
two plus two equals five because two
point four plus two point four is then
and the other half of the schools teach
two plus two equals four and then all
these people come out of the schooling
systems and they can't agree on basic
ideas like math then we're in a really
impre like a challenging social place so
so two parts of that one
you're starting to see that now within
the public school system exactly they're
doing it they're the ones going two plus
two equals four is racist
right the other thing i would say is
this how many parents are gonna send
their kids to a school right within a
marketplace of education opportunities
how many parents are gonna send their
kids to the school that's teaching them
two plus two equal five
maybe some would
do we think it's going to be a majority
do we think it's going to be enough to
actually cause a problem if that if that
is such a concern with education why is
it not the same concern with respect to
food or with respect to where you buy
your vehicle or with respect to where
you buy your healthcare because quite
frankly all of those are really
important decisions as well and here's
what we find is that within the
marketplace when people have options
the the the best way to ensure quality
is by giving people choice not by
putting a government board in charge of
it right like i don't want the
government misinformation board deciding
what math looks like
because they're probably not going to
come up with good ones so yeah in a
perfect world it would be great if
everyone you know
could learn math the same way they don't
right so being able to have different
options for students hopefully to come
to the you know a logical and rational
conclusion at the end of it but the idea
that the government taking over that
process is more likely to get us a good
product i don't i don't see it i mean
we've seen the exact opposite right
every year since the department of
education was founded test results have
absolutely not improved but fundings
funding adjusted for inflation has
improved and so i think to your point
yeah we really didn't see this kind of
bizarre two plus two equals five
thinking creep its way into public
schools until long after the government
had complete control over them and
frankly if you were to go back to a time
where schooling was more a product of
the community and someone walked into
the little red schoolhouse and said hey
let's teach our kids two plus two is
five they'd get laughed out of the room
no one would be willing to do it you see
thomas massey's proposal
yes the department of education will
will terminate on december 31st 2020 or
whatever yeah one sentence the best
troll move he ever made and i love
thomas massey the best troll move he
ever did those when betsy devos was put
in charge of department of education of
the trump administration massey put out
this massive thing going do you really
want this woman in charge of your
child's education support hb you know
and it was the same thing right right
right and he had all these lefties
retweeting him so yeah we need to get
behind this building because i don't
want betsy devos in charge but that was
he was making a solid point you're right
you don't want this person to charge
your child's education so let's get rid
of the mechanism that they use to try to
control it and put you back in charge
well so one point that the right and
that libertarians will make when we're
arguing with the left is
you guys should want to abolish this
particular state institution because it
might be the case that eventually
someone who's more sympathetic to our
views will be in charge of it as opposed
to someone who's sympathetic to your
worldview the reason i think that
criticism never works and won't work and
won't persuade them is because as a
conservative or as a more right-leaning
person a more traditionally minded
person you know that on the local level
your solutions are generally things that
most people support and would be willing
to buy into and i think the left knows
that in order to get their agenda across
they need a gigantic bureaucratic state
that's forcing these things onto
everyone so the risk of a conservative
being periodically in charge of it is
worth it to them because the only way
they can have any success is if it's
forced onto everyone from some
institution of that sort i think that's
right i i think they've i think they've
realized that
you know the the old attitude camera
what it was that you know conservatives
come in and end up conserving things
that the liberals did 20 years earlier
yep um and you saw that within the uk
with the national health service right
now now there's not a single
conservative candidate that's going to
run on the idea of like look this has
been a colossal failure on a number of
levels maybe we need to privatize more
no it's always put us in charge of it
and we'll we'll run it more efficiently
and more effectively and so yeah i think
they i think they've made the the deal
here and they realize that the more
bureaucracy they get eventually they
push the overton window in the direction
they want and they end up controlling it
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you